okay so that brings us into summer and
obviously with that comes a mixing
things but first on June 10th is the
Warcraft movie all I have to say about
it it actually looks a little better
than I would have expected but we don't
know anything about it so we'll see on
that a week later on June 17th we get
the sequel that feels a little late but
it's Pixar so we'll take it and we'll
love it it's finding dory though I am
gonna admit I don't know as of right now
if I'm that excited for it for me feels
like I'll just stay home and watch
inside out again the bing-bong scenes of
course okay and then a week after that
June 24th a movie that is very close to
my heart and that has a title that does
not at all correspond to its released a
Independence Day resurgence despite what
I said a second ago
I think this sequel even though it's 20
years later is actually not too late at
all in fact I think it's right on time
but that's only because they've got one
of the best ideas for a sequel that I've
seen in a long time with humanity having
actually learned from what happened in
the first movie and the alien technology
that's left over I mean they built a
freaking solar system defense unit and
all kinds of crazy weapons and it's just
a great example rather than just
repeating the same thing as the first
one they took that original idea and
built upon it and heightened it and I
know that this franchise isn't that
important to all of you but since I grew
up
reciting that speech so much it actually
became part of my fourth of July
tradition that's true today we celebrate
our Independence
I just can't wait to see that world
again and what's even more exciting is
that this movie works of the sequel does
well it's actually supposed to launch a
whole new trilogy and that just excites
me so much
welcome to earth indeed ok then actually
in the month of July on July 15th we get
the new Ghostbusters movie which is
actually coming 27 years after the last
Ghostbusters movie though this one seems
to be mostly a reboot with its
all-female cast so I actually find a lot
of those ladies incredibly hilarious so
while I still know nothing about the
movie I've got my fingers crossed and I
am hoping for the best July 22nd we get
Star Trek Beyond and I don't know I've
got to see more from it still I really
liked the first one and the last one
wasn't quite as good as that one but
this one's still far off so we'll see
here's what I will say about this
franchise it's doing a really good job
as standing apart now it's not fair
anymore to compare it to Star Wars even
though both updates were relaunched by
JJ Abrams the fact that Justin Lin was
chosen to direct this one cements those
differences even more Star Trek has
become a bit more like fast and furious
in space and actually I don't think
that's necessarily a bad thing those
movies are pretty fun to watch and also
Simon Pegg wrote this one yeah actually
you know what I changed my mind
that's my birthday week I'm feeling
pretty good about it I'm gonna give it a
chance whoo excited for Star Trek moving
on July 29th brings us another sequel
and it's Godzilla resurgence and it's
actually not a sequel to the gareth
edwards 2014 one its instead they're
like 29th or 30th of the japanese ones
if you're Zil ahead get excited
otherwise moving on we are into August
and boom Suicide Squad August 5th now I
will say this movie early on had some
stuff that look not so great but DC has
since done a really good job of getting
me excited for it I'm actually really
curious now to see what jared leto is
gonna do with the Joker I want to see
Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn actually
almost all of the characters seem pretty
exciting and that's actually my favorite
thing about this in March we'll get
introduced to our starting hero line up
with the dawn of Justice and just a
little over four months later we're
getting a ton of really interesting
villain DC's throwing us headfirst into
their Cinematic Universe I wouldn't even
be surprised if they started giving
standalone movies to the villains too
but in general just that the fact that
this is all finally happening that's
just very cool I'm very happy for you DC
now I know that I haven't mentioned any
TV shows for a bit but do remember that
summers always low on TV premieres I'll
remind you that the release dates for
Luke Cage and Iron Fist haven't been
announced yet though my guess is we'll
probably get Luke Cage maybe somewhere
in the fall not too far off of when
Jessica Jones from yours as for Iron
Fist nothing's official but I have a
feeling we're gonna be well into 2017
before we meet Mr Dan R and speaking of
shaky release dates on October 7th we're
supposed to get Channing Tatum in the
role that maybe he wasn't born to play
but we'll still be fun nonetheless
gambit the issue is Channing and the
director Doug Liman they didn't get
locked in until pretty recently so it
just seems kind of unlikely that they'll
be able to meet that date it's pretty
soon don't see that as a bad thing
though because the last time that a
fox-owned superhero movie got rushed we
got the not so Fantastic Four no thank
you
I'd have heard they take their time and
do it right I haven't heard much about
the script but Doug Liman directed edge
of tomorrow and I freaking love that
movie but with Fox's plans to make x-men
and Deadpool and gambit all part of the
same cinematic universe and by crosses
characters over which is potentially an
awesome idea it's just extra important
that the individual movies can live up
to their expectations basically just Fox
Mon Cherie
take it easy oh but speaking of
impossible expectations that I think
might still somehow get met on November
4 things get strange Benedict strange
dr. Cumberbatch yes you get it Doctor
Strange it's one of the most interesting
characters in the Marvel Universe and
he's being played by one of the best
actors in our universe and it's the
first Marvel movie after Civil War so we
seen that aftermath and the analyst is
still looking for Infinity stones are
still too out there I think we'll get
one in this movie and it's gonna be
weirder than a lot of Marvel movies
event which is I'm just so excited for
them to keep expanding this universe I'm
very excited for this movie and just
before we get to the last few
juggernauts of the year I'm gonna take a
second here to mention season three of
black mirror we don't have a release day
for you yet we just know that Netflix
acquired it and says to expect a bunch
of episodes in 2016 but I'm serious this
is one of the best TV shows around
especially if you've ever wished that
something like the twilight zone would
come back reflect on our current modern
society that's what this is it's creepy
it's sometimes beautiful it's all about
what a messed up future where you
be added to don't even research it just
check it out make sure to go at least
more than one episode though the first
ones a little extra weird it's still
good we've got a pig in it and you'll
see what I mean just stick with it a
very interesting show if you like ex
machina you might like this
moving on ok so I was twenty sixteen
years it's and we've only got three more
movies that I think people are gonna go
pretty nuts for on November 18th we
return to the Harry Potter universe with
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and that's it seventy years before the
Harry Potter movies and this time it
looks through the other side of the pond
it all takes place in New York also did
you know that if this movie does well
which yeah it's gonna do very well it's
supposed to launch an entire new trilogy
of these movies so let's just hope that
the curse of prequel trilogy s does not
affect Wizards okay and finally we are
in December of 2016 and there are two
movies worth mentioning here one is the
Assassin's Creed movie that comes out in
December 21st though we all know like
anything about it other than the fact
that Michael Fassbender is wearing the
clothes which that alone is pretty
interesting but the other movie just a
few days earlier on December 16th is the
one that I think has a chance at topping
civil war as the biggest hit of the year
rogue one now I'm not guaranteeing that
it's gonna beat out Civil War but when
you remember that the titles actually
wrote one a Star Wars story then you
remember why it might come out on top
road one is actually incredibly
interesting it's the story of how the
first Death Star plans got to Princess
Leia before the events of a new hope and
it's the beginning of the Star Wars
anthology movies which is like an
attempt to blow out the Star Wars
universe kind of like how the Marvel
Universe already is for people that
thought force awakens was too much like
a new hope rogue one might be exactly
what you're looking for everything about
it suggests that it's gonna be
completely different from any Star Wars
movie we've ever had before and it just
in general it sounds like a great movie
and even if it only does half of what
the force awakens did it'll still be one
of the most successful movies of all
time by the way let's remember it's
civil war comes out on top or rogue one
you can tell me in the comments but
they're both owned by Disney cuz as the
saying goes you never bet against the
Mouse
right so that's 2016 in terms of what
film and TV properties I think the
Internet's gonna be pretty excited about
this year but if you cannot wave if
you're just like too pumped and you need
more content right now there's a bunch
of links in the description to other
videos we've made about a bunch of those
movies and TV shows so go give those to
watch and by the time we're done I'm
sure all of these things will have
already come out now if you think
there's something that I missed you are
more than welcome to put in the comments
but if you actually want to have a big
impact on what we plan to cover this
year and you want this thing to be
included you've got to fill out our poll
there are links to it in the description
really easy to find one is a version of
the poll that'll be on our website or
website by the way covers all of this
stuff all the time and the other one is
a link that goes through our Facebook
fan page the benefit of that one is you
don't just tell us what you care about
but actually how much you care about it
we'll share the results on our official
Twitter add new rock stars in the next
couple of weeks but remember all we're
trying to do is get on the same page as
you so you can also just hit us up
directly I'm Phillip you hit me up at
fimo on Twitter at fimo nose on
Instagram you want to suggest a picture
I should cover or something you can hit
up Ted at Ted Marsden on Twitter we know
what we like we just want to know what
you like so let us know I clearly we've
got a lot of work to do in a lot of
videos to make so we'll see you in those
gotta go bye